une impasse de saint benoît où l'on
découvre un visage bien connu des
réunionnais si cette salle de répétition
et la rue porte le nom d' henri madoré
ce n'est pas un hasard oubliettes il
aurait sûrement pas qu'ils étaient en
vie madoré aurions adoré à mon avis
c'était un combat de de la chanson
réunionnaise guitariste accusation pour
une petite pièce pour un petit robe
comme on disait ça à l'époque nous
faisait l'aubade henri madoré aînés
avenue de la victoire à saint-denis le
11 avril 1928
ses parents habitent à l'époque dans un
quartier populaire dès son plus jeune
âge qui dort et aime les chanteurs de
rue à l'école celui que l'on surnomme
grimace est un enfant terrible et
bagarreur à tel point qu'il se retrouve
souvent chez le docteur vergès après son
certificat d'études
henry entre au poste c'est à vélo qui
livre les plis mais sa carrière de
postiers s'arrête à la suite d'une
collision contre un train il prend alors
son banjo et joue loulou pitou ou jules
arlanda quelques verres à la boutique et
ils composent les premiers morceaux
qu'il chantera dans les bals les
mariages ou à l'entracte au cinéma en
1955 il enregistre son premier disque
deux titres marmaille l'habite et
l'amande ans
tapez à lisbourg protin au tata saubade
rennes ou à la mode dans les années 50
henri madoré est une figure connue des
dionysiens look de corbeaux toujours en
noir lunettes de soleil cloué sur le nez
à toute heure il est aussi connu de
toutes les boutiques pour son penchant
pour laraque au fil des années la
télévision et la radio remplacent les
chanteurs de rue henri madoré ne trouve
plus sa place
oubliée il noie sa tristesse dans
l'alcool en 1981 une voiture le fauche
il restera handicapé la lente
autodestruction de l'artiste commence
elle s'achèvera le 31 décembre 1988 par
la mort de tito